90 91 92 93 94 95 96 97 98 98
c'est pour ça c'est incroyable
c'est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
et on dirait qu'elle vient d'être
sélectionné pour juste prix
Le Millionnaire comment ça va ma chérie
en plus je la connais bien ah oui
ça fait tellement longtemps
c'est grâce à mon ami c'est grâce à mon
ami que je suis venue te voir parce
qu'on a une belle histoire je connais
depuis longtemps mais
pour l'émission pour des démissions pour
des émissions
merci merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais ça n'arrivera ici jamais jamais
on arrivera ici je t'en prie je te le
jure jamais le mal triomphale si je te
jure
je suis vraiment désolé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
je te jure merci est-ce que alors c'est
toi qui va décider est-ce que j'offre un
smartphone à benime quand même oui quand
même d'accord même si c'est le camp du
mal
tout le monde est gentil tout le monde a
un cœur
merci les sérieux merci de mes amours
c'est que je t'aime